at first glance this looks like a
completely normal beach resort it's 7
a.m. and the loungers are neatly packed
away the clothes hooks ready for a new
day of bathing time to give Trieste
speech pool a quick tidy up before the
guests arrive the regular guests are
already waiting to get in like what
melaa veero samosa is best in the
morning we always have the same lounges
the pool opens at 7:30 just like many
others in the area but there was one
major difference women and children
enter to the left the men to the right
maura bc aki makes sure everyone abides
by the rules when she's not controlling
the tickets she takes care of the cash
desk the pool attendant knows many of
her customers habits many women just
come for a couple of hours at midday to
sunbathe and relax separated from the
men on the other side this wall keeps
men and women apart and the women's side
is often much busier than the men's a
ticket for the pool still costs a modest
1 euro if the City Council decided to
privatize the pool because it's not
profitable there would be a revolution
in Trieste and Miko would be among those
in the uprising she's one of the younger
regular visitors but is just as much in
favour of upholding traditions as the
older guests
the women are glad the wall is there to
separate them from the men it protects
them from curious glances if you have a
bit of spare tire after the winter and
aren't in the best shape you have stress
and less problems then he would have on
a normal beach where men can look at you
you feel a lot freer a hundred and ten
years ago the female bathers were still
completely covered up Trieste was under
Austrian rule back then the so-called
Lantana pool below the lighthouse opened
in 1903 complete with the dividing wall
it survived two world wars Austrians
Italians Germans and Yugoslavians and
has also outlived some unsavory episodes
in history after World War one my
grandfather got rid of his lice hair
before he came back home in wartime the
soldiers washed on one side and washed
their horses on the other
fortunately times have changed but men
are still men Mattie Claudio is trying
to persuade the ladies to meet up in the
water through a slit in the wall they
might be separated on the beach but the
men and women can mingle freely in the
water
if your wife asks you who the blonde was
you were talking to in the water that
can lead to arguments like most of the
people here the 74 year old has been
coming since he was a child but things
aren't always this peaceful people often
fight for the best spot on the beach I
try to persuade the regulars that they
don't have a right to reserved spots
that's the rule here but peace normally
returns by the end of the day now the
pool is left to the seagulls and the
Bano Lanterna is ready for another day